let's stay with that rumbling royal rift
the palace has now responded
as you just heard to the allegations
made by the duke and duchess of sussex
in a
fairly short statement uh this is it in
full it says the whole family is
saddened to
learn the full extent of how challenging
the last few years have been for harry
and megan
the issues raised particularly that of
race are concerning
while some recollections may vary they
are taken very seriously and will be
addressed by the
family privately harry megan and archie
will always
be much-loved family members
well as we mentioned earlier the rift
has divided opinion here in the uk
and of course in the united states to
talk more about this is the television
presenter trisha goddard
who joins me now from the united states
great to talk to you trisha a lot to
discuss of course
and first of all your reaction to that
statement as i say a fairly short
statement from
buckingham palace and source to her
majesty
the queen and perhaps the most relevant
paragraph is that saying the issues
raised particularly
that of race are concerning and while
some
recollections may vary they are taken
very seriously and will be addressed by
the family
privately they clearly want to close it
down and have that
discussion between themselves do you
think that's going to happen
well can i just come to the statement at
first i think the whole statement is
important because
i've been a mental health campaigner for
over 35 years
and i've been saying all along when
one's
child or grandchild is you might call it
acting out
or acting angrily or speaking out it's
usually because they feel
they've been banging their head against
the brick wall and they haven't been
heard
and i've been saying all along that they
just need to be heard all you need to
say is i hear you
i hear that you're in pain and let's
talk about this privately
and this is exactly what the queen has
been saying
um and as far as the the and as far as
the race
issue is concerned as well i don't think
they need to say any more
or put any more detail i think uh
trying to have some kind of witch hunt
on the part of the media or individuals
about who said exactly what
about race is is a waste of
time and energy because the empire
basically
has been built on colonialism and all
sorts of
practices that are now recognized to be
archaic
and oppressive so there's a lot of work
to be done but
i just think saying you know what we
hear your pain
we take these things very seriously and
we're going to talk about them
is a massive first step i think it's
wonderful
well let's talk about someone you took
issue with for not appearing to take
that issue very seriously and trish you
know i'm talking about
piers morgan they're now ex-itv
presenter well uh
i think he was right to go in the end
and particularly on the issue
she touched on in your first answer of
mental health when he just quite
frankly said he didn't believe meghan
markle
again as a mental health camp a
campaigner you
have to believe if somebody says they
are in pain to the point where they
don't want to go on
you you absolutely believe them and even
even
if you choose to be as ignorant not to
do that
when you make those kind of statements
there are hundreds of
thousands of people listening and
watching that
who are in pain and might be thinking of
reaching out might be thinking of
of of doing themselves some harm and
want to reach out for help
and when somebody in in a very uh
prominent position in the national media
says oh yeah i don't believe
it it it compounds all of that fear of
if i ask for help if i say i can't go on
people won't believe me it's a very
dangerous game to play
not just with meghan markle and if you
remember prince harry in the interview
said that he went to a very dark place
as well but to every
single person who's struggling now i i i
i'm not going to gloat
about piers deciding to go um
and he he i you know he's probably
i don't know how he feels i'm not even
gonna put myself in his head but
i wonder i actually wonder if piers
isn't going
through a tough time or hasn't been i
know
he um is kind of prone to
to banging on about something but
i i i always worry when somebody gets
so fixated on something
i always i'm not i'm not talking about
mental illness here
but i'm just talking about stress so you
don't know what's going on
at home for anybody um and i
might be completely far of the mark but
if he
you know i i'm not going to gloat about
anybody
um going through something as stressful
for losing their job
however however you might want to be
a level there you know label their
behavior you know you reap the
consequences of what you do
however that is not to ignore that that
person may be in some
kind of pain to have to come to that
decision in the first place it might be
a good idea for you and peace to have a
a private chat trisha and i know of
course you weren't going to gloat but
just in terms
of itv is a huge organization is it
sending out the right signals in that we
understand
from the statement they had a discussion
with piers morgan
and they decided not to oppose his
decision to leave does that
send out an important signal from itv
that it does take this issue very very
seriously indeed
yes it does i mean i i've worked with
mind the mental health charity and time
to
change uh which is an organization set
up to battle
the stigma against mental health and
before that as a government advisor in
australia on mental health
and itv has actually signed up
and signed a pledge to really you know
back uh the chipping away a way of
mental health stigma
and promote mental good health um and
then of course we've got the channel
four documentary on caroline flack
coming up
and it's no good media outlets on one
hand saying just be kind
and backing mental health initiatives
and then having
any one of their very prominent
presenters or anybody
sort of setting you back 25 years
so you know the world is changing the
world is changing don't
i think the days of belligerent
interviewing and
and just barking at someone until they
back down or shut up
and you have your say i think that kind
of interviewing
is over oprah did the whole velvet glove
if she didn't get the answer she wanted
she kind of
circled back after a little while and
look what she got
look what she got it's not all it's a
spectacle if you just shout at somebody
it's a spectacle it's a ball ring it
doesn't get
information and if being a journalist is
getting information
it doesn't work which was uh precisely
how you operated when you were over here
trisha come back soon
very good to talk to you